god bless mommy god bless daddy god
bless you amen forgotten someone hey
keep thinking me I forgot to bless me
God bless me a tooth it's a meaningless
funniest writer ready to put the smile
back on our faces we fight that war but
it is over what am i doing about it
you're doing what you're good at writing
plays I had enough of making people
laugh I want to make them see I need to
get out of London somewhere quiet and
trying to think for once you're going to
live here this is your new mommy says
you're writing a book stop people going
toward me I think they'll book Isadora
said I did you're the only one that does
it really like if you wrote a book for
me
I definitely read it shall we go for a
walk
aren't you working it doesn't seem
likely do you think of a good name for a
donkey your
we've got in a minute these are the jar
name they just want to make honey yes I
completely forgot about bees creepiest
find something to be happy about I think
I've got something for us Ernest and I
are putting your bear in a book or
putting you in it too what do you call
me in the book your real name
Christopher Robin
let's the hunters in the snow the
creatures in the story of toys their
toys but the woods are real Winnie the
Pooh it's rather inexplicable yes
Evening News Christopher on the front
page
why does everyone like Winnie the Pooh's
to watch after the war there was so much
sadness then Winnie the Pooh came along
shall we go to the woods I've got heaps
of writing to do I'm afraid
he has to be allowed to grow up he has
to know he's important radio into the
newspaper interview he can't do all this
rather go doesn't he's a little boy
[Music]
come on men watch it home I should think
[Music]
you